This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In September 2015, Duke University's football team promoted its backup quarterback to starter. This was a little bit of a shake up because the new starting quarterback was a total rookie, stepping up to take a man to the team. Duke's new quarterback may have been inexperienced,
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。2015年9月，杜克大学橄榄球队将他们的替补四分卫提拔为首发。这在当时引起了一小阵轰动，因为这位新的首发四分卫是个彻头彻尾的菜鸟，直接挑起了大梁。杜克大学的新四分卫可能缺乏经验，
but he sure did look the part. He was exactly the kind of person you'd cast in a movie about a team trying to turn their luck around. Dude is 6'4", 225 pounds, has boyish good looks and an aweshocks grin. That's aweshocks producer, Sam Greenspan. Meanwhile, in Orange County, California, a public defender was making headlines for his work investigating how local law enforcement had been stacking the deck against defendants. Newspapers show him in a standard suit with wireframe glasses, ductile hair, and a goatee.
但他看起来确实像那么回事。他完全是你会在一部关于一支试图扭转运势的球队的电影里挑选的那种演员。这家伙身高6英尺4英寸（约1.93米），体重225磅（约102公斤），长着一张充满男孩气的帅脸和一个憨憨的微笑。那是憨憨的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘。与此同时，在加利福尼亚州奥兰治县，一名公设辩护人因调查当地执法部门如何对被告不利而登上各大新闻头条。报纸上的照片显示他穿着标准的西装，戴着细框眼镜，头发整洁，留着山羊胡。
He's got the look of a 20-year veteran of the courts who's managed to keep hold of his ideals. Meanwhile, in the West African country of Burkina Faso, a group of armed soldiers in military fatigues forced their way into a cabinet meeting and asserted their control over the government. In each of these cases, the quarterback, the attorney, the coup, newspaper articles about each of them described them in exactly the same way.
他看起来就像是一位在法庭上摸爬滚打了20年的老兵，同时还设法坚守着自己的理想。与此同时，在西非国家布基纳法索，一群身穿迷彩服的武装士兵强行闯入内阁会议，并宣称他们接管了政府。在每一个这样的案例中——无论是四分卫、律师还是政变——关于他们的报纸文章对他们的描述都完全一样。
They were all written up as being straight out of central casting. Calling something or someone from central casting is a kind of cultural shorthand for a stereotype or archetype. Something so visually perfect that it's like it's been designed. The first time Barack Obama flew in Air Force One, he said to the pilot, I've got to say you're out of central cast. You're exactly what I want.
文章都把他们写得像是直接从中央选角公司（Central Casting）走出来的一样。把某事或某人称为“来自中央选角公司”是针对刻板印象或原型的一种文化简写。视觉上如此完美，就好像是被设计出来的一样。巴拉克·奥巴马第一次乘坐“空军一号”时，他对飞行员说：“我得说，你真是从中央选角公司出来的。你完全是我想要的。”
The pilot Air Force one will look like. If you do a new search for the phrase straight out of central casting, you'll get tons of hits about athletes, business executives, politicians, billionaire philanthropists. But every noun that you'll find an article that makes reference to a proper noun central casting in Burbank, California. Morning. I'm going to central casting, please. I've known the phrase straight out of central casting for a long time, but I'd never really
空军一号飞行员应该有的样子。如果你在网上搜索“直接从中央选角公司出来”这个短语，你会得到大量关于运动员、企业高管、政治家、亿万富翁慈善家的搜索结果。但在你找到文章的每一个名词中，都会提到加利福尼亚州伯班克市的一个专有名词——中央选角公司。早上好。我要去中央选角公司，请。我听过“直接从中央选角公司出来”这个短语很久了，但我从来没有真正
stop to think about where it came from, and so I was quite surprised to learn that central casting is a real place. I know, right? It's like learning that ACME is a real company, and that they still make Ann Vills. Even my taxi driver, a long time resident of Los Angeles, even he didn't know central casting was real. Central casting is in Burbank, California in the San Fernando Valley, and it's where the vast majority of extras come from.
停下来去想它究竟从何而来，所以我很惊讶地得知中央选角公司是一个真实存在的地方。我知道，对吧？这就像听说ACME是一家真正的公司，而且他们还在生产铁砧一样。甚至我的出租车司机，一个长期住在洛杉矶的居民，连他也不知道中央选角公司是真实存在的。中央选角公司位于加利福尼亚州伯班克的圣费尔南多谷，绝大多数群众演员都出自这里。
Okay, I am on South Flower Street in Burbank, California outside of the central casting building. It's a nondescript two-story office building, the kind of place you'd expect to find in orthodontist. In every Monday, Wednesday, and Friday, starting in the very early, early morning. People line up outside central casting. When I got there at eight o'clock on a Monday morning,
好的，我现在在加利福尼亚州伯班克的南弗劳尔街，中央选角公司大楼外面。这是一栋不起眼的两层办公楼，就是那种你会在里面找到正畸医生的建筑。每个星期一、星期三和星期五，从大清早开始，人们就会在中央选角公司外面排队。我周一早上八点到那里时，
there were about 50 people in line. It would grow to about 100 over the next hour. And at the very front was a woman named Karissa Garrow. I got here at 3, 10 in the morning. 3, 10 a.m.? Yeah. So it's already been a long day.
队伍里大约有50人。在接下来的一小时里，人数增加到了大约100人。排在最前面的一个女人名叫卡里萨·加罗。我早上3点10分就到这儿了。早上3点10分？对。所以这已经是漫长的一天了。
Yeah, it has. The people in line at Central Casting aren't there for auditions. Karissa and everyone behind her in line are there for the chance to fill out some paperwork, take a headshot, and get entered into Central Castings Database for extras. They will not be cast for speaking roles, though many, if not all, are hoping that a director or producer will like their look and give them some dialogue.
是的，确实如此。在中央选角公司排队的人并不是来试镜的。卡里萨和她身后的所有人来这里是为了有机会填写一些表格、拍一张大头照，并被录入中央选角公司的群众演员数据库。他们不会被选为有台词的角色，尽管很多人（如果不是全部的话）都希望导演或制片人会喜欢他们的外表并给他们安排一些台词。
Just like how John Wayne and Marilyn Monroe and Brad Pitt got started. The line of Hollywood hopefuls stretches down the sidewalk. Some people have broad lawn chairs or blankets to sit on. And they all look, well, they look like they're straight at essential casting. There's a handsome Texan in a suit and tie, fresh face to the prospect of showbiz. Friends called me over and I'm from Texas.
就像约翰·韦恩、玛丽莲·梦露和布拉德·皮特当年的起步方式一样。好莱坞追梦人的队伍沿着人行道延伸开去。有些人带着宽大的草坪椅或毯子坐在上面。他们看起来都……嗯，他们看起来就像是从中央选角公司直接走出来的一样。这里有一个穿着西装打着领带的英俊德克萨斯人，对演艺界充满了新鲜感。朋友叫我过去，我是从德克萨斯来的。
So they was like, hey, you want to do some background work background work central casting you can go over there. There's a female body builder I do fitness competitions so I'm trying to build myself as a brand and that industry as well. A guy who calls himself Kid Radioactive I'm gonna be famous even though it's already hot and most of the people here have been waiting for three four five hours people are are cheerful, optimistic even. Then, at around 9.30 a guy emerges from inside central casting. He's handing out these laminated slips of paper. They kind of look like oversized bookmarks.
所以他们就说，嘿，你想做点背景演员的工作吗？背景演员，去中央选角公司，你可以去那儿。还有一个女健美运动员，我参加健身比赛，所以我也在努力在那个行业把我自己打造成一个品牌。一个自称为“放射性小子”的家伙。我要出名，尽管天气已经很热了，而且这里的大多数人都已经等了三、四、五个小时，但人们依然兴高采烈，甚至是乐观的。然后，在大约9点30分，一个家伙从中央选角公司里面走了出来。他正在分发这些过塑的纸条。它们看起来有点像超大的书签。
These are the tickets in to today's registration process. He only makes it halfway down the line when he runs out. You didn't get one, I'm sorry. Should we wait and see if somebody doesn't have their pay for it? No, ma'am. Thank you. Come back Wednesday. Where's he morning?
这些是进入今天注册流程的门票。他才走到队伍的一半就发完了。你没拿到，我很抱歉。我们应该等等看有没有人不要他们的了吗？不，女士。谢谢。周三再来吧。几点来的？
It's kind of lined up between like four, maybe five in the morning. Central Castings Bouncer is named Russell Leblanc. I'm a safety specialist, this is passing out the cars this morning. Right. So your people is either best friend or worst enemy in the morning? Yes, pretty much. One person protests and if you ask Russell about exceptions, but most of the 60 odd people who didn't get tickets
大概在早上四点到五点之间排队的。中央选角公司的门禁人员名叫罗素·勒布朗。我是一名安全专家，今天早上负责分发卡片。对。所以你的身份在早上来说要么是最好的朋友，要么是死敌？对，差不多吧。一个人发出抗议，如果你问罗素关于特例的事，但那60多个没拿到票的人中的大多数
retreat to their cars wordlessly. Then the door to central casting opens up and the 50 or so left golden tickets in hand slowly file in. The first job that any aspiring film actor gets is usually as an extra, known in the industry as background actors. They're the people who really make the film without your being aware that they're present. That's Anthony Slide. My name is Anthony Slide.
都默默无言地退回了他们的汽车。然后中央选角公司的门打开了，剩下的50名左右手握金券的人缓缓鱼贯而入。任何有志成为电影演员的人得到的第一份工作通常都是群众演员，在行业内被称为背景演员。他们是真正成就了这部电影，而你却甚至没有意识到他们存在的人。那是安东尼·斯莱德。我的名字叫安东尼·斯莱德。
I am the author of 76 books, I believe, if they can't correctly, on the history of popular entertainment, and one of them is Hollywood unknowns, a history of Hollywood extras, stand-ins, bit players, and stunt people. Even though the industry has shifted to calling them background actors, Anthony Slide still calls them extras. They were always called extras in the early years, Fiodor Dreiser, the novelist, called the Atmosphelians, which is a rather nice title,
我想，如果数得不错的话，我是76本书的作者，内容关于大众娱乐的历史，其中一本是《好莱坞无名小卒：好莱坞群众演员、替身、特约演员和特技演员史》。尽管这个行业已经改称他们为背景演员，但安东尼·斯莱德仍然叫他们群众演员。在早期，他们总是被称为群众演员，小说家费奥多尔·德莱泽称他们为“氛围营造者”，这是一个相当不错的称呼，
I think. If you're a director, you need Atmosphelians, because if you try to shoot a film out in the world with regular people, the risk you take is the people walking around suddenly aware they're being filmed, and so they're suddenly going to start waving at the camera, mugging or whatever. Plus, you're going to have to shoot the same scene a bunch of different times, and so they're suddenly going to start waving at the camera, mugging or whatever. Plus, you're gonna have to shoot the same scene a bunch of different times, and so you need to be able to tell your actors, background included, where to go and what to do. You need people who are paid to listen to you.
我想。如果你是一位导演，你需要氛围营造者，因为如果你试图带着普通人在现实世界中拍电影，你所面临的风险就是周围走动的人会突然意识到他们正在被拍摄，于是他们会突然开始向镜头挥手、扮鬼脸或做其他事情。另外，你必须把同一场戏拍摄好多次，所以他们会突然开始向镜头挥手、扮鬼脸或做其他事情。另外，你必须把同一场戏拍摄好多次，所以你需要能够告诉你的演员，包括背景演员，去哪里以及做什么。你需要那些拿钱听你指挥的人。
It's about control, yes. In the early days of cinema, the Hollywood machine had near complete control of extras, both on the set and off. People would come from all over seeking fame and fortune. And to get work, people converged on the gates of the movie lots, hoping to get cast for the day. They were desperate. Many were exploited. So many horror stories were emanating from Hollywood.
这关乎控制，是的。在电影的早期，好莱坞机器对群众演员有着近乎完全的控制，无论是在片场还是在片场之外。人们从四面八方赶来寻求名利。为了获得工作，人们聚集在电影制片厂的大门前，希望能获得当天的角色。他们绝望了。许多人遭到剥削。好莱坞流传着太多的恐怖故事。
That by the 1920s, Hollywood had been nicknamed the Port of Missing Girls. The Port of Missing Girls is a place where women flocked in their thousands and their tens of thousands in the hope of getting into films and they were all very vulnerable. They were reliant upon the men at the studios particularly the casting directors, the assistant directors who would hire them and a lot of times these men would simply ask for sexual favors as a reward for hiring them to appear in a movie for a dollar a day. Extras who did get hired were often not paid what they were promised.
以至于到了20世纪20年代，好莱坞被戏称为“失踪女孩之港”。“失踪女孩之港”是一个成千上万、数以万计的女性蜂拥而至的地方，她们怀揣着进入电影界的希望，而且她们都非常脆弱。她们依赖于制片厂的男性，特别是选角导演、副导演，他们会雇佣她们，而很多时候，这些男性仅仅要求性作为雇佣她们以每天一美元的薪水出演电影的回报。被录用的群众演员往往拿不到承诺的薪水。
By 1925, the state of California was threatening to investigate Hollywood if they didn't clean up their act. And so as a means of regulating the industry and keeping the government off their back, the Motion Pictures Association of America, the MPAA, established central casting. A centralized clearinghouse to match people who wanted to be extras with the people who wanted to hire them. Now, instead of just picking one of the major movie studios and just standing around at the gates all day hoping to be picked, people who wanted to be extras could register with
到1925年，加利福尼亚州威胁说，如果好莱坞不收敛一点，就要对他们进行调查。因此，为了规范行业并让政府少管闲事，美国电影协会（MPAA）成立了中央选角公司。这是一个集中的信息交换所，旨在将想要成为群众演员的人与想要雇佣他们的人匹配起来。现在，人们不用再随便挑选一个主要电影制片厂并在大门外站上一整天希望能被选中，想要成为群众演员的人可以在
central casting. So now, they could wait by their phone, hoping for a call like... Hello. Does Maple Jones? Yes. Berkeley Company. Warners. Be there at 8 tomorrow.
中央选角公司注册。所以现在，他们可以在电话旁等待，希望能接到这样的电话……喂。是枫树路吗？是的。伯克利公司。华纳。明天8点到那儿。
Street Close. Extras also called into central casting, constantly. So much so that the operators developed super quick ways to relay information. If there was no work, they'd say, NERK. NERK! They wanted the extras to try again later, they'd say, TRE-LE. But as cinema took off, and as silent films gave way to talkies, the need for extras only grew.
便服。群众演员也经常给中央选角公司打电话。以至于接线员开发出了超级快捷的方式来传递信息。如果没有工作，他们会说：“NERK。”“NERK！”他们希望群众演员晚点再试，他们会说：“TRE-LE。”但随着电影业的腾飞，随着有声电影取代无声电影，对群众演员的需求只增不减。
And central casting had to get more sophisticated and it's tracking and recruitment of extras. This is the team that's doing the registration today. Back in present day central casting, executive vice president Jennifer Bender is showing me around. So then afterwards they'll come over here and get their photos taken. This office is one of three.
中央选角公司不得不对其群众演员的追踪和招募变得更加老练。这就是今天负责注册的团队。回到当下的中央选角公司，执行副总裁詹妮弗·本德正带着我四处参观。然后他们会来到这里拍照。这个办公室是三个办公室之一。
Central casting is now in Burbank, New York, and New Orleans. Between all three offices, we've got about 90,000, almost 100,000 people. It's like there's a small city living inside their computer servers, an extremely diverse and infinitely indexable city. This is Spain. I am Sam.
中央选角公司现在在伯班克、纽约和新奥尔良都有分部。在所有三个办公室之间，我们大约有90,000人，快到100,000人了。就像他们的服务器里住着一座小城市，一座极其多元化且拥有无限索引的城市。这是西班牙语。我是萨姆。
Brandy, nice to meet you. Jennifer introduces me to Brandy Hawkins. Brandy takes me on a test drive of how the central casting database works. She opens up a window on their custom-built software which has just about every search parameter for a person you can imagine. Hight, race, shoe size, bus size tattoos, location of tattoos, missing lens, how much nudity you'll do. Now she just needed a target. Do you want to look for like your photo double? Oh my god, yeah, let's do that.
布兰迪，很高兴见到你。詹妮弗把我介绍给布兰迪·霍金斯。布兰迪带我实操体验了中央选角公司数据库的工作原理。她打开了他们定制软件的一个窗口，里面几乎包含了你能想象到的关于一个人的所有搜索参数。身高、种族、鞋码、胸围、纹身、纹身位置、身体残缺、你愿意接受多大程度的裸露。现在她只需要一个目标。你想找个像你照片替身的人吗？哦天哪，好啊，我们来试试吧。
Okay. So I, this is just looking at you, this is what I would do, but you can't get a friend of mine. No, please. So I would go in maybe the 24 to 35 range. Okay. And I would do Caucasian, male. Like, six, six, one, six, two. It's pretty good. So I would do like six to six, three.
好的。所以我，这只是看着你，这就是我会做的，但你不能找我朋友。不，请吧。所以我会选24到35岁这个年龄段。好的。我会选高加索人，男性。比如，6英尺到6英尺1英寸，6英尺2英寸。这挺好的。所以我会选6英尺到6英尺3英寸。
I would do hair color, and then I would brown, coat, but 40, 42, some more. morning. I'm good at this. And like 32 ways. 32 ways. And something we would just do a search. And one by one a stream of tall brown haired 30-something white dudes all scroll by. And then we just kind of scroll through and see kind of who we think that like might come up that anywhere near That's pretty good Like I would submit him he looks like he'd be like your long-lost brother. Oh
我会选发色，然后我会选棕色，夹克，不过40，42，再多一点。早上好。我很擅长这个。腰围大概32。32码。然后我们就会进行搜索。一个接一个，一群高个子、棕色头发、30多岁的白人帅哥在屏幕上滚动而过。然后我们只需浏览一下，看看我们觉得谁可能会符合条件，哪怕有一点接近……那挺好的。就像我会推荐他一样，他看起来就像你失散多年的兄弟。哦
Man that sounds so unsettling. It was a little unsettling. I just wanted to stand up and shout. No, I'm unique I asked Brandy how she got comfortable talking so explicitly about what people look like. It was very difficult first because I came from a human resources background and there were so many things you couldn't do. Like you couldn't hire people based off of their looks. Whereas now that's what it's all about,
天哪，听起来真让人不安。这确实有点让人不安。我只想站起来大喊：不，我是独一无二的！我问布兰迪她是如何习惯如此直白地谈论人们长相的。一开始非常困难，因为我出身于人力资源背景，有很多事情是不能做的。比如你不能根据人们的长相来雇佣他们。而现在，这正是全部意义所在，
like they'll literally say, I need African-American mail, six feet tall that fits these sizes. And, you know, like if you're creating a basketball team, it, you know, it's not going to look like a realistic basketball team if there are all these Caucasian looking guys who are five foot four. And so to do this, central casting and pretty much every casting agency that deals with background, there are plenty of others. Their callouts can be pretty blunt. Central casting's Facebook page is full of descriptions such as, and this is a real one, quote,
就像他们会直截了当地说：“我需要一个身高6英尺、符合这些尺码的非裔美国男性。”你知道的，如果你在组建一支篮球队，如果全都是身高5英尺4英寸的白人帅哥，那看起来就不像是一支真实的篮球队。因此，为了做到这一点，中央选角公司以及几乎所有处理背景演员的选角机构——还有很多其他的机构——它们的招募要求可以相当直白。中央选角公司的Facebook页面上充满了这样的描述，这是一个真实的例子，引述：
looking for a hip, attractive man and women who appear to be Asian in their 20s with trendy wardrobe, no visible tattoos. To an outsider, this language can really feel abrasive. It's clear that this line of work demands that you categorize and stereotype. Kristen Barona is a senior casting director at Central Casting. And to get a feel for how she works, I asked her how she'd cast a couple different locations, starting with a dive bar. A dive bar, I would probably do an older
“寻找一个看起来是20多岁、衣着时尚、没有明显纹身的时髦迷人的亚裔男女。”对于局外人来说，这种语言确实会让人感到刺耳。很显然，这行工作要求你进行分类和贴标签。克里斯滕·巴罗娜是中央选角公司的高级选角导演。为了感受她的工作方式，我问她会如何为一个不同的场景选角，首先是一个小酒馆。一个小酒馆，我可能会选一个年长的
Caucasian guy bartender, kind of maybe on a little bit on the bikery side or a little bit on the sketchy side, because they're always at a dive bar. Then I would probably do a second bartender that would be like a tatted up hipster and some women that have probably been, you know, through it. Auto body shop.
白人男酒保，可能有点像骑摩托车的风格，或者有点可疑的风格，因为他们总是出现在小酒馆里。然后我可能会安排第二个酒保，那会是一个纹满身的潮人和一些可能已经经历过生活沧桑的女性。汽车修理厂。
Auto body shop. Auto body workers, mostly Hispanic. Guys, I would do definitely a guy in his 40s kind of ponchy with maybe a mustache. And then some younger guys that are kind of running around. I would probably do a female in her 50s that's the receptionist. I mean, I picture myself in the place
汽车修理厂。汽修工，大多是西班牙裔。至于男人，我绝对会选一个40多岁、有点大肚子、可能留着胡子的男人。然后是一些跑来跑去的年轻人。我可能会选一个50多岁的女性来做前台接待员。我的意思是，我把自己想象成置身于那个地方
in what I would see. What I would see. What I would see. Background actors are supposed to look like they belong there. So casting directors play to our expectations about how we think the real world looks. And sometimes in doing so, they end up perpetuating those expectations. Casting directors are trying to strike a balance between authenticity and expectation.
以及我会看到什么。我会看到什么。我会看到什么。背景演员应该看起来他们就属于那里。因此，选角导演迎合了我们对现实世界长相的期望。有时这样做，他们最终巩固了这些期望。选角导演正试图在真实性和期望之间取得平衡。
They're constantly looking at the real world and wondering if it matches the way they would cast it. Here's central casting executive vice president Jennifer Bender again. The other week I was in New York and I was walking down the street and there were, this is just so silly, there were more blondes than brunettes. And what's very stereotypical if you're casting a New York street scene is they don't want any blondes because people think of New York they think of Brunettes, right? And I just thought to myself, if I were to cast the scene doing a New York straight scene, I would be fired because this it doesn't even look like it should be really here. Back in the registration room, the people who are waiting outside all morning sit at chairs facing a PowerPoint presentation.
他们一直在观察现实世界，并想知道它是否符合他们会进行选角的风格。这是中央选角公司执行副总裁詹妮弗·本德。前几天我在纽约，我走在街上，有——这太蠢了，金发女郎比深发色女郎更多。如果你为纽约街头场景选角，非常刻板的做法是他们不希望有任何金发女郎，因为人们一想到纽约就会想到深发色的人，对吧？我当时心想，如果我要为纽约街头场景选角，我会被开除的，因为这看起来根本不应该发生在这里。回到注册室，整个早上都在外面等待的人们坐在面向幻灯片展示的椅子上。
Essential casting employee comes out. All right, guys, good morning. How's everyone today? I think it's been out there for quite a bit. employee comes out. The central casting orientation is pretty much like any new employee orientation. The next form is the i9 form. That should be the second to last page in your pocket. Though every now and then, there are some forms to fill out that you would not find at most places of business. And on to level of immunity. For this one, I do need everyone to select one thing. So yes, would be everything, of course. No is swimsuit for women.
中央选角公司的员工出来了。好了，各位，早上好。大家今天怎么样？我想大家在外面等了挺久了。员工出来了。中央选角公司的入职培训和任何新员工入职培训差不多。下一张表格是i9表格。这应该是你们资料袋里的倒数第二页。尽管偶尔也会有一些表格需要填写，是你在大多数商业场所找不到的。接下来是关于免疫级别的。对于这个，我确实需要每个人选择一项。所以“是”将涵盖所有内容，当然。“否”是女性穿泳衣。
Partial would be naked seen from the rear from the end. So just keep that in mind. Of course, you can always edit this. There are boxes to check for tattoos, piercings, missing body parts. If you can dress in drag, There are boxes to check for tattoos, piercings, missing body parts. If you can dress in drag, you can dress like a clown, you can juggle. There's also information about how the payment system works, and a session on identifying the signs of heat exhaustion, and who to talk to if you're feeling ill on set.
“部分”是从后方拍摄的裸露镜头。所以请记住这一点。当然，你随时可以修改它。这里有勾选纹身、穿孔、身体残缺的方框。如果你会反串，你还可以打扮成小丑，你会杂耍。这里还有关于薪酬体系如何运作的信息，以及一场关于识别中暑先兆以及在片场感到不适时该找谁谈话的培训。
After about an hour of document signing, everyone gets a headshot. And that's it. They are released back into the world where they will wait for a role. There's a cynicism that one could take here. That central casting is about turning humans into objects. It is one of the only, if not the only job, where you are hired solely for what you look like. On the other hand, though, one could argue that this is progress. Here, everyone will be seen. The young, the old, the short, the tall, the housewife, the ex-gang member, the bombshell, the amputee.
经过大约一个小时的签署文件，每个人都拍了一大大头照。就这样。他们被放回现实世界，在那里等待角色的到来。人们可能会对此抱有一种愤世嫉俗的态度。即中央选角公司就是把人类变成物品。这是唯一一份（即使不是唯一一份也是其中之一）完全仅凭你的长相来雇佣你的工作。但另一方面，也可以认为这是进步。在这里，每个人都会被看到。年轻的、年老的、矮的、高的、家庭主妇、前帮派成员、性感尤物、截肢者。
This is a pathway into showbiz that's not about nepotism or cronyism or who you'll sleep with. At central casting, people fill out eye-nines and get some knowledge base about what to expect on set. And actually get paid. And maybe, just maybe, one of them could become the next Brad or Marilyn. But until then, they'll check Facebook and wait by their phones for the call. Hey Jill, this is Jimmy from Central Casting. Hey, I'm calling to see if you want to work American Crime Story tomorrow. Alright, so you're going to be a media type at 9.30am? Correct.
这是一条通往演艺圈的途径，它不关乎裙带关系、任人唯亲，也不关乎你跟谁睡过觉。在中央选角公司，人们填写i9表格，获得关于在片场该有什么期待的知识储备。并且实实在在地拿到薪水。也许，只是也许，他们中的某个人能成为下一个布拉德或玛丽莲。但在此之前，他们会查看Facebook，守在电话旁等待召唤。嘿，吉尔，我是中央选角公司的吉米。嘿，我打电话是想问你明天愿不愿意去拍《美国罪案故事》。好的，所以你明天上午9点30分要演一个媒体类角色？没错。
Awesome, thank you Jill. Of course, alright, bye bye. Hey Dusty, this is Jimmy from Central Casting. Hey, how's it going, man? Good, good. Are you available tomorrow? Awesome. Alright, so you're going to be a media type at 9.30am?
太棒了，谢谢吉尔。当然，好的，拜拜。嘿，达斯蒂，我是中央选角公司的吉米。嘿，最近怎么样，老兄？很好，很好。你明天有空吗？太棒了。好的，所以你明天上午9点30分要演一个媒体类角色？
Correct. And you're all set? Alright, you too. Bye bye. We type at 9.30 a.m. Correct. And you're all set? Alright, you too. Bye-bye. We're booked up on the Caucasian spots. So we need one more African-American one Hispanic one, Asia. Still graffing your kiss. I'm longing to linger till the day.
没错。都安排妥当了吗？好的，你也是。拜拜。上午9点30分要演媒体类角色。没错。都安排妥当了吗？好的，你也是。拜拜。白人名额已经约满了。所以我们需要一个非裔美国人，一个西班牙裔，一个亚洲人。……
99% Invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan with Katie Mingle, Avery Truffman, Kurt Colstead, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Davian Nelson, Ellen Lewis, Grant Wilfley, Claire Tanner, Andrea Hume, Bill Maranella, Devon Brown, Jack Wallace, Alana Goldstein, Raquel Lamoth, and everyone at Central Casting for Letting Us in the Front Door. The people you heard online were Carissa Garrow, Cory Lo, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of me, dream of meW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interiors firm not even remotely out of central casting in beautiful
本周的《99% Invisible》由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，合作制片人包括凯蒂·明格、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、库尔特·科尔斯特德以及我罗曼·马斯。特别感谢戴维安·纳尔逊、埃伦·刘易斯、格兰特·威尔夫利、克莱尔·坦纳、安德烈娅·休姆、比尔·马拉内拉、德文·布朗、杰克·华莱士、阿拉娜·戈德斯坦、拉quel·拉莫斯，以及中央选角公司的所有人，感谢他们让我们走进大门。你听到声音上线的人有卡里萨·加罗、科里·洛……（此处歌曲歌词省略）……W旧金山，节目制作出自ArcSign办公室，一家既不在中央选角公司也不沾边的建筑与室内设计公司，位于美丽的
downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的照片和链接，并收听《99% Invisible》的所有单集，你必须访问99pi.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。